foreign
[Music]
I'm always amazed at these married men
who managed to maintain double lives
married men in management and uh what
double lives
that's so much work bro so much work I
don't work bro this dude okay well you
don't have to be involved I can't even
maintain One Life yeah yeah that's
because you're involved yeah because
you're a good dad that's the key dude
you got to be absent in both if you're
not involved and you just come in and
out whenever you want to and if you're
absent both you have room for third you
know what I mean and you're always
working and also you can say you're
doing business abroad or your military
or whatever and then you couldn't have a
kid and family in a different country
you know what's really sad is as uh I
had a friend who uh thought she had a
perfectly normal uh like childhood with
her two parents and then
um her dad passed away on a on a flight
he had like a heart attack on the plane
and then they were like oh he was going
back and forth to China for business
like he always does but they found out
that he never had business in China he
just had another wife
and it sucks that he passed away and you
can't even like can't even seek
resolution you can't forgive him you
can't get mad at him how did they find
out I did look through records and
figured out why he was going and they
had his stuff and like his letters and
sweaty house so what you're saying is he
never got caught
Hannah's uh got uh relatives in the U.S
because this her Grandpa or great
grandpa did exactly this damn because he
worked on um like a shipping company so
he had a he he he had a family here in
the states and then uh family back home
in Wales dude I feel like I hear about
this all the time it sounds so it sounds
Tuesday
this is not uncommon dude but you know
it's funny it's like if you're just a
shitty husband or shitty dad and you're
not double lifeing yeah what excuse do
you have yeah you're a piece of [ __ ]
dude all right so listen at least have
another family this guy's name is Oliver
he's from the UK he's 44. he was living
with his wife during the week
the whole time his wife believed he was
a cruise ship captain okay oh my God
that is Grandpa which is a good way to
be like gotta goal
he doesn't even know boats
so so on the weekends he lived with a
separate fiancee
who believed that he worked for BMW of
America so then he's gotta like go you
know gotta go sell those Beamers like
we're a beamer collared shirt that's
really good and so he was bringing in
lots of money but even in his uh ways of
like gaining income even that was a scam
he made 400k
selling fake cruise ship tickets on his
Tugboat
you show up and it's a raft and he goes
welcome to the enchanted boat yeah so
this guy was he was raking in lots of
money because he would sell these fake
tickets and then take that money and
then just gamble the [ __ ] out of it and
make more gambling or lose it yeah so he
was he was basically in all facets of
his life just like fraudster yeah but
that's why he's so good at it it's
because he does it everywhere he goes if
you're 100 a fraud in every facet though
are you high level the truth are you the
Michael Jordan are you the Michael
Jordan of Friday imagine the freaking
detectives like that's legit yeah like
not not one thing did he tell the truth
this is the real deal this guy's good so
that just means he lives in an alternate
universe yeah and the sad thing is it
like I was the first thing I wanted to
find out was how did this guy get caught
yeah doesn't say but uh it does say that
like he's getting the maximum penalty
for this or whatever from the judge
because they're just like you there's no
portion where you had remorse like you
were yeah willfully pulling these scams
his business probably got him caught up
and then everyone else found out
afterwards he maybe mixed up the cruise
ship and BMW thing
does it save if his wife caught him or
what happened it doesn't say how how he
got mad but like yeah now everything's
out in the open and interesting stories
like that I'm like I wonder how they
were as a child
you know what I mean like were they just
same thing like through school through
their Social Circles through with their
parents like is it just everything is
just like a compulsive lying contact
what makes somebody like turn into a
professional con man they probably learn
from their parents dude I think it's
probably like a really difficult
expectations at least from the person's
own perspective that's hard to meet so
it's easier to lie instead of like
failing on those expectations and it
just starts becoming like a it's unbuilt
momentum and it's like um instant
gratification because it's like it's
almost like you know like when you know
we're kids and we make fun of posers
right yeah because they want to look the
part but they don't actually skate or
they want to be a DJ but they don't
practice to become a DJ they just want
to look like one sure yeah they want the
image and then they just go like this
with the turntables but they don't know
how to beat match and [ __ ] you know like
I feel like I feel like it starts with
that with that like people are just they
want the the the the image but they just
suck at practicing to doing it yeah the
judge did point out one trait that uh I
felt like was pretty uh telling so
freeloaders people with a freeloading
mentality are just one step away from
conning they're just not clever so like
if someone's a freeloader and they're
also like kind of devious then you can
completely see why they would just be a
condom they already want free [ __ ]
anyway they don't want to work for
something and then now they're like well
if I can like get an angle on it yeah
dude I was listening to this interview
with the um this guy named Brett Johnson
Johnston and he's the number one cyber
criminal like of all time FBI Most
Wanted list wow and he was talking about
how when he was growing up he was like
dude my mom ran every single scam known
to man dude she would like it in every
stage of his life it was always like all
right we ran this scam all right what's
next and just constantly going to the
next she would go to Coal Mines and just
start taking coal and then selling it
and undercutting people she would she
would like and then they started doing
that as kids and then instead of saying
like why are you doing that what are you
like this is [ __ ] up she would be like
where'd you get that click over vision
how'd you get that how can we run this
scam too I want it and so like the kids
will be running scams the Mama's running
scams and it just became this thing that
like he had to compulsively do for his
whole life until like he created the
first like eBay scam selling like beanie
babies and then like painting them
making them seem like they're like first
editions or whatever the [ __ ] oh right
taking the money and then nobody else
could get you for it so creative and he
just kept doing that to the highest
level until he became like the number
one most Wanted like cyber these people
are so good like they are so good to the
point of like don't you ever think of
like doing something else they get more
long-lasting like no that's like Catch
Me If You Can though right that's like
[ __ ] Leo and Catch Me If You Can
where it's like well you're so good at
being bad that I just couldn't work for
the government yeah and that's actually
what happened to this dude he like hit
him too saying the same thing dude all
those scams that you do when you hear
about crypto or those Chinese people hit
you up randomly like hey what's up dude
or whatever hey what's up I'm lonely or
whatever like he broke he was like
breaking all that down to a science of
like wow how to do that and just giving
people a little bit of Hope and then
just taking all their [ __ ] yeah and it's
really [ __ ] up but he was like yeah it
was a crazy time and you really do need
like sociopathic tendencies where you
feel nothing from people but most scams
work because they Prey Upon people's
desires exactly so if you're people's
greed yeah yeah because like those
Nigerian scams and shits because you're
greedy yeah you're like oh no I need to
help you you gotta dangle the carrot
that's true yeah but also sometimes they
Prey Upon the kindness like like if
someone's like oh I got hurt I need help
and then they [ __ ] with your kindness
you know so those are the those are the
really I only like losing money to
greedy skins yeah yeah because you can
only blame yourself right yeah uh my
friend was a compulsive Gambler or he is
still and your friend
no so he's a he's a hardcore guy he lost
tons of money tons of [ __ ] money lost
friends money lost a lot of friends
right down bad and and so like I I just
don't want to be around this dude
because it's like dangerous but it makes
sense because same story since childhood
for him it was normalized and especially
in Asian culture like you do it every
new year you do it like during special
times you do it all the like some his
parents gambled all night they go to the
casino like no one said gambling is
wrong right it's bad but we grew up
Christian and we were just like you
don't even [ __ ] touch that [ __ ]
exactly so I know I'm doing something
that's a little risky for him it's like
this is just this is associated with
partying It's associated with love it's
always it's just it's associated with
like finding like being somebody right
because then when he wins his whole
family's like Yay like and then so it
sounds like that's the same with the
scammer if your mom gave you that
attention that like good boy you did a
good [ __ ] job so then now you're a
good game yeah yeah scamming becomes
your love language it becomes who you
are so that's hard to [ __ ] break
Timmy why can't you be like Bobby get a
big scam we're trying to we're trying to
score big so while we're trying to kind
of rationalize in our heads about why
people do these like double marriage
like you just think that's so much
trouble to do right I bet it's fun in
this case it kind of does shed a little
bit of light on why because he did it so
that he could commit fraud under the
names of his spouses and like people
that trust him so it's not so much that
he just wants to like cheat and do all
this part of a bigger plan yeah so the
main thing oh that's that's okay then
yeah that's fine
oh why'd you say that at the beginning
this guy's ambitious he's got goals It's
like because usually as a as a dude he's
just horny yeah your mind your mind just
goes like ingredients so much trouble
yeah I thought it was you know adultery
and I was like that's [ __ ] up this
guy's just a CEO I think when you see
somebody living a double life you have
to really check and go
is there a financial gain to like doing
that because maybe a lot of times there
aren't and maybe if you never catch it
then you just think he's a scumbag but
like dude there could be something there
yeah or it's a two birds for one stone
type of deal where you're like I happen
to love this person and I could steal
their money
I thought I saw something where like
when 23andMe and those things started
coming out people started like finding
all these people related right and then
it's like I've seen so many examples of
they're like oh yeah I had no idea he
was such a great dad or whatever and
then I'm like well maybe there are cases
where they have these secret families
but they're still like there as like not
a deadbeat right they're just good Dads
twice really good multitaskers yeah good
multi dads monetize your horniness
compulsive fathers compulsive fathers if
you had to do you think you have what it
takes to run two relationships
simultaneously no you could never I can
even do one
it's like it's so hard well no it's not
hard it's just like it's just a lot a
lot of if you're involved right yeah
it's so much but if you were like if
that was your only job of just having
relationships with people you could
probably do it I think we all could if
that was if we didn't have other
businesses we're all ambitious people I
think it's all doable there's only so
many hours in a day I think I think we
can do it or you'll go look at me like
that I I feel like it's an open
conversation like if everybody's uh on
the same page I feel like that would
work oh because then you're not hiding
anything because the guilt it's the
guilt like are you cool with three fake
families because I want to do three fake
families right like if you're cool with
that let's do it like you gotta find a
person that's just like chill yeah yeah
you gotta find someone who's down a scam
I'm not down for you to have any other
husbands but I'm gonna have three wives
this life I'm like oh I could settle
with it it doesn't sound impossible
that's how we know we're normal folks
because guys like this they have no
conscience when it comes to it yeah they
need to communicate better yeah this is
communication
Pick Your Truth love them and theft them
they'll steal from our significant
others
[Music]